l'espace saint quentin à montigny fête
ses 25 ans et pour l'occasion s'offre un
plan de rénovation à hauteur de plus de
6 millions d'euros sols plafonds parking
code couleur tout va être revu les
travaux vont débuter à la fin de l'année
pour six mois l'objectif reste est
attrayant face à la concurrence alpha
parc de inauguré ce mardi aux clayes
sous bois ou la refonte de vélizy et
parler d'eux hervé donnio le directeur
estime disposer d'atouts différents on a
par exemple une capacité de parties de
plus 4000 places ce qui pèse qui
permettent de venir faire ses courses en
toute tranquillité et puis voilà on
offre aussi
quelque chose d'atypique parce qu'on est
là voir un centre fermé et alain centre
ouvert avec une rue piétonne et un
bassin mais il faut sans cesse innover
pour continuer à attirer la clientèle
familiale et capter d'autres clients
comme les salariés qui gravitent autour
de l'espace saint quentin on as plus de
cent mille employés qui travaillent près
de la zone donc on va faire des offres
dédiées et refaire des des offres
ciblées pour les sièges sociaux
notamment bouygues malakoff médéric ou
bientôt pour accueillir le siège social
de mercedes des pack de bienvenue ont
été réservées aux étudiants de la fac de
médecine tout proche l'autre défi c'est
la restructuration du voisin skywest en
quarts et privés ouest sur site
seulement 20 magasins sont ouverts sur
60 on va relancer ce site avec le projet
carré privé qui verra le jour sur la fin
de l'année 2013 et comme nous devons
lancer des travaux importants de
restructuration nous devons en fait
fermer certaines boutiques nous sommes
bien sûr en fait on fait ça en accord
avec ses boutiques demain dans le nouvel
espace dédié au luxe à prix cassés les
habitants pourront retrouver le cinéma
un pôle restauration
le bowling wii va déménager et rejoindre
à l'espace saint quentin dans les locaux
de l'ancien cinéma et il n'y aura plus
qu'une seule enseigne go sport une
transformation qui va débuter au premier
trimestre 2013